so you sent me this is there any
explanation or
uh well so this there's this guy stephen
crowder i don't know
he does his show um he's from canada
originally
he doesn't i i i i i know stephen
crowder is okay
the thing is when
when you have someone that go on
benjamin talk about
it can't be on the show there's a new
gimmick i don't know if you noticed this
and i don't know if it's in this clip
but it's
from this around this part of the show
that i pulled from
where he's talking and he's like yeah we
got people coming in we're going to be
doing all this and
the producer was like yep we got a lot
of people coming in
and he looked like he was not like you
know he always likes to go like
royce what do we got coming up next week
and then you are allowed to talk this
guy
talked out of turn and he got dude they
look like
crowder was just shooting [ __ ]
daggers at him
like he does that thing where he's like
[Laughter]
so uh talk out of place on my show he's
a nut dude you can tell he's a psycho
it is the drowning dance i don't know
when that started exactly uh
also uh defendgavin.com thank you so
much to gavin mcinnes let us know what
you think how much you enjoyed gavin and
third share we have a bunch of people
obviously who come in and third job i
think we have pantelas
next week i think i think it's next week
or maybe i don't know
but uh he's coming in sooner or later
we're gonna have some uh some kind of
more permanent people we're just uh
we're just trying and then sometimes
we'll come in and third chair we've had
some big names so then get in trouble
and can't come back even though we love
them
i don't know who that is i i honestly
don't know who that is now of course
obviously somebody sent that to me
immediately today i was like you [ __ ]
see this [ __ ]
did you see that from yesterday's
episode we're just uh we're just trying
and then sometimes we'll come in and
third chair we've had some big names and
then get in trouble and can't come back
even though we love them
[Music]
can i say one of the cheesiest internet
meme phrases of all time
what did he mean by that
what do you think he meant by that it
could be coombs
could be okay do you think it's one of
our guys
either kumio or owen yeah
well somebody says nimr but i don't
think it's never never only did a show
once and it was just a favor to owen so
and he said big names also by the way
he's not talking about nimr because
there's no there's nobody clamoring for
nibbler to come back you know
yeah do you have that eric nimmer guy
back he said big name but then we also
have to use crowders
but maybe this is like a blind item like
when anti-lawyers sometimes will say a
big name and he'll mean like
physically big right huh boom maybe
they're doing a blind item
what big time what big
name recently was dropped from the
crowder lineup like
you big oh do they mean big or big
hmm and what's up with this mustang what
the [ __ ]
there was something else that i was
going to say uh i can't oh
it is so that that was the that was
pretty much it
uh but it was said today it was from
yesterday's episode and i'm
very curious if that's in reference to
mr benji because he's been getting
hammered on his twitter
um crowder has yeah about owen
because he's been like you know we're
gonna have jack and we're gonna go after
him and we're gonna talk free speech
with lauren southern and gavin
mcguinness and everybody's been
hammering him with oh yeah while you're
talking free speech
you [ __ ] answer for owen benjamin
copyright striking people
so i don't know man man i'm
all right i hope he's banned that would
be
so good that would be so good it would
be safe it would be another
another twist of the screw